9. sınıf tayfam kaldığımız yerden 9.
sınıf matbook serimizde video ders
kitabımızdan yolumuza devam ediyoruz.
Güncel maarif modelde. Ha benim kitabım
hala gelmedi bu arada matbaadan stoklar
da güncellendiğinde linkleri paylaşıyor
olacağım ama PDF'leri soran, kitabı
soran herkes rehbermatematik.com sitesi
hem güncellemde hem yenilendi. PDF'lere
de oradan ulaşacaksınız. Haftalık yayın
akışına da oradan ulaşacaksınız. Her
şeyi oradan takip edebilirsiniz
rahatlıkla sizler için yeniledik orayı.
Şimdi kaldığımız yerden yola devam.
gönder gelsin hocam dedim. En son ne
yaptık? Beceri temelli sorularımızı
çözmüştük. Gerçekten sağlam güzel
sorular vardı. Şimdi üstüne koyarak
gidelim. Üslü ifadenin kuvvetini
alacağız. Üslü bir ifade var. Onun da
kuvvetini alacağız. Ha tabii ki ispatını
yapacağız ama önce ne demek bu? Üslü bir
ifadenin kuvveti alınırken üstler
birbiriyle çarpılır. Bugüne kadar zaten
sen bu kuralı biliyordun ama sebebini
araştırdık mı? Ona da bakalım. X bir
gerçek sayı. A ve B pozitif tam sayı
olmak üzere verilen ifade bu. Tamam mı?
Ne yapacağım? Bunun anlamı nedir?
Üstünün tanımını bildiğin için
soruyorum. Hocam, x üssü A ifadesinden
yan yana kaç tane yazmam gerekiyor? B
adet yazmam lazım. Bak burada B tane X
üssü A var. E sonra ne yapıyorduk hocam?
1 tane, 2 tane, 3 tane, B tane sayıyorum
ya. B tane A'yı saydığında aslında sayı
ne yapar? B tane A'yı topluyorsun.
Dikkat et. A + A + nokta nokta nokta A.
Ne yaptım? Burada B tane var hocam.
Aslında buradaki toplam a adeti a x b
adet. O halde üslü ifadeyi yazarken ne
yazdık? A x b yazdık. E üslü ifadelerde
değil ama çarpma işleminde mesela üstlü
ifade de var ama çarpma işleminde de
değişme özelliği yok mu? Var hocam. E
bunların yeri değişse problem olur mu?
Misal x üssü b x a. Peki ben x üssü b'yi
yazsam sonra a'yı yazsam bir şey değişti
mi? Değişmedi. Aslında tüm bu değerler
birbirine eşit. Demek ki üssün üssü üslü
ifadenin üssü neymiş? Üstsün üstü farklı
bir şey. Üslü ifadenin üssü çarpılırmış.
Tamam. Şimdi ama burada bir sıkıntı var.
Üslülerin çarpılması ile üstün üssün
alınması birbirinden farklı kavramlar.
Önce bu kavramı bir öğrenelim. Burada ne
var? 2 üssü 3 var. Ne yapıyorum? Bunun
4. kuvvetini alıyorum. Ha o zaman hocam
üstleri çarpıyorum. 3 kere 4'ten ne
geldi? 12. Demek ki bu ifade 2 üssü
12'ye eşit. Doğru. Geldi mi altına
dikkat et. 2 üssü 3 var. Bunun üstünde 4
var. Yani bu 3'ün üstünde şurada bir 4
var. E 3'ün 4. kuvveti ne yapar hocam?
81. O zaman burası ne oldu? 2 üssü 81
oldu. Gerçekten karıştırıldığında
dünyalar karışır. Yani o kadar enteresan
bir nokta. Halbuki aynı üstleri
görüyoruz ama bu 4 3'ün de üstünde. Peki
geldim buraya. Demek ki benim
karıştırmamam gereken kural neymiş?
Buraya stickerla yapıştırdık. x üssü a
10un üstünde b ifadesi eşit değildir. X
üssü a üssü b ifadesine. Aman buraya
dikkat. Şimdi bu öğrendiğimize gel bir
hemen sorularla tekrar edelim. Üslü
ifadelerin değerlerini yazınız diyor.
Üstlü bir ifade var burada. 2 üssü 3.
Onun da üstünde 2 var. Ne demek bu?
Üssün üssü çarpılır. 2 kere 3'ten 6.
Geldim. 4 kere 0'dan 0. Yani aslında
kısaca 1 ha yazalım dersem bak buraya da
64 yazarım. Geldim çarptım. Bu ifadeyi
eksiler birbirini götürdü. Cevap ne
oldu? 4ün karesi oldu. Yine aynı şekilde
geldim buraya. Yalnız burada dikkat
edeceğimiz nokta ne hocam? İçeride eksi
varsa önce buradaki kuvvete bakacaksın.
En dışarıdaki kuvvete. Baktım hocam ne
yazıyor? 3. 3 nasıl bir sayı? Tek bir
sayı değil mi? Bunu da yazalım. Peki tek
sayı içerideki işareti değiştirebilir
mi? Değiştiremez. O zaman eksim aynen
kalacak. -4 üssü 3 ile 0'ı çarptım 0
geldi. Heh. 4 üzeri 0 ne? 1 önünde ne
var? Eksi var. -1 cevabı. Yine aynı
şekilde devam ediyorum. Bak kritik nokta
şurası hocam. Bu ifade tamam içerisi
negatif -16 çıkıyor ama üstünde karesi
var. O zaman diyorum ki üstteki ifade
çift olduğu için aha siriye kadar gitti
mevzu. Dedim ki üstteki ifade çift
olduğu için içerideki işaret değiştirir.
Artı olur. Bir kere bunda hemfikir
miyiz? Güzel. Şimdi şu iki arkadaşı
çarp. 2 x 4 8 2 üssü 8 ama pozitif.
Geldim. Bu tarafla devam. Yine dikkat
etmem gereken nokta burası. 6 nasıl bir
sayı hocam? Çift sayı. İçeride ne var?
Parantezin içerisinde negatif bir ifade
var. İşaret neye dönüşecek? Çift olduğu
için en dışarıdaki kuvvet pozitife
dönüşecek. 3 kere 6'dan 18 gelecek. 1
üssü 18. İşlemin sonucu yine 1 olacak.
Devam ettim. Artık üssün tek olduğunu
gördüm ya. Kafa rahat. Eksiye bir şey
yapmadım. 2 kere 3'ten 3 üssü 6. Yine
eksiyi gördüm. Dışarının tek olduğunu
gördüm. Sıkıntı yok dedim. 2 üzeri ama
-2 üzeri 2 kere 3'ten 6. Yola devam.
Durdum. Dedim ki 0 nasıl bir sayı hocam?
Çift sayıydı. Çift sayı olduğu için
gerçi içeride ne yazarsan yaz cevap artı
olacak ama hani şu iki üssü bir
çarpalım. 0 geldi. E onun da zaten
cevabı ne geliyordu? 1 geliyordu.
Aslında içeri bile bakmama gerek yoktu o
soruda. Peki yine buradayız hocam.
Burada ne var? Bak burada da çift ifade
var dışarıda. Şunla bak arasındaki farka
dikkat et artık. Cevap ne gelecek?
Pozitif. Üstleri çarptım. Ne yaptı? 2
kere 3'ten 6. 3 üzeri 6 yaptı.
Aradığımız cevaplar bunlardı. Peki
devam. Seri halle sorularımızı çözelim.
Hocam en dışarıda 0 var. İstersen 3
uzatmayalım. Direkt cevabım 1'dir. Şimdi
bu ifadeleri çarpacağım. Çarpalım. Artı
dedim. Ne de olsa pozitifti. -1 ile
-2'yi çarptım. Cevap ne geldi? 2 geldi.
Arada eksi var. Hocam bak bu ifadelerde
de yine üstleri çarptığımda burası ne
oldu? 0 oldu. E 5 üzeri 0 demektir.
Orası da yine aynı. Bir şey değişmedi. 1
+ 3ün karesinden 9 5 üzeri 0'dan 1. Şu
1ler birbirini götürdü. Cevabım sadece
kaç olacaktır? 9 olacaktır. Vurdum
cevabı 9'a geldim bu tarafa. Peki hocam
bu işlemin sonucu nedir? Tek tek
inceleyelim istersen. Burada üstte
rasyonel ifade olması bir şeyi
değiştirecek mi? 25/100 değil midir bu
ifade? Evet. 25/100 1/4 değil midir?
Evet. 16 üssü 1/4. Sen şimdi şunu
diyeceksin. Hocam biz daha bunu
öğrenmedik. E ben de sana diyeceğim ki
16 dediğiniz sayı kaç? 2 üssü 4 değil
mi? Peki 16'nın üstündeydi ya. Yani
kısaca 2 üssü 4'ün üstünde değil midir
bu ifade? Aynen öyle. E buradaki
arkadaşları üstleri ne yapıyorduk?
Çarpıyorduk. Kısaca 4 x 1/4 oldu mu
2'nin üstünde? E 4'ler birbirini
götürdü. Geriye ne kaldı? 2 kaldı.
Amanım bak buralar kritik noktalar. Yine
49'umu yazdım. 0,5 aslında 5/10 mu
demektir? Onu da sadeleştirdim. 1/2 mi
kaldı? E yazalım bakalım. 49 üssü 1/2.
Tekrar düşündüm. Dedim ki 49 7in karesi.
Hocam 7in karesini yazdım. En dışarıda
1/2 var. E üsler ne yapılıyordu bu
durumda? Çarpılıyordu. 2 x 1/2'den
cırtsana cırtsana geriye sadece 7 kaldı.
Geldik sonuncusuna. 32 üzeri 2/ 10
demektir. 0/2. Peki 32 dediğim sayı 2
üssü 5 mi demektir? Yazdım. 2/10'u
sadeleştirdim. 1/5 mi geldi? Yazdım. E
üstün ifade üstlü bir ifade var içeride.
Onun da üstü alınmış. O zaman onları ne
yapıyorduk? Çarpıyorduk. Yine çarparak
yazdığımda buradan cevap ne geldi? 2.
Artık nihai sonuca geldik arkadaşlar.
Burada olayı bitirelim. 2 dedim, artı
dedim. Ardından 7 dedim, eksi dedim. Bak
şimdi buradayım tam olarak. Ne yaptık?
2'yi çıkardık. Cırt sana. Cırit sana
bunlar gitti. Cevap sadece 7'dir. 20
soru biter hocam. Gelsin bakalım
sıradaki başlık. Yine bildiğimiz
noktalar. Belki yıllardır görüyorsun
bunu ama artık iyice işi pratiğe dökme
vakti. Üslü ifadelerde çarpma işlemi
nasıl yapılır? Bir kere üslü ifadelerde
çarpma işlemi yaparken tabanların aynı
olabilme ihtimali var gelen soruda. Eğer
ki tabanlar aynıysa üstleri ne
yapıyoruz? Topluyoruz. Neden topluyoruz?
Tabii ki her zaman biz işin
mantığındayız. A x A x A x nokta nokta A
yazdım ya. Burada kaç tane var hocam? X
tane. Çarpı devam ediyor. A üssü Y ne
demek? A x A x nokta nokta x a dedim.
Burada kaç tane var? Y tane var. Peki
ben hepsini saymaya kalktığımda toplam
burada kaç tane a oldu? X + Y adet oldu.
O halde üslü ifade olarak yazarsam nasıl
yazacağım? A üzeri x + y. Toplam oradaki
a sayısı ki bu da üstlü sayının
tanımından geliyor. Direkt üstüne
yazıldı. Eee hocam bazen tabanlar aynı
oluyor. Tamam işlemi yapıyoruz. Tabanlar
farklıysa ne yapacağız? Eğer tabanlar
farklı üstler aynıysa tek çatı altında
biz bunları ne yapıyoruz? Toparlıyoruz.
Orada da ortak üstü alıyoruz. İşte
burası çok çok kritik. Özellikle bunu
tersten kullanacağım. Tersten kastım şu
hocam. A üzeri x b x ifadesi artık
üstler tek bir paranteze alınıyor. Hop.
X onların dışına geliyor. Bunun anlamı
ne demek? Parantezde ya hocam bu üst hem
A'ya ait hem de B'ye ait. Ama sorularda
daha çok biz bu şekilde verilen ifadeyi
buna çevirmeye çalışacağız. En sık
kullanılan hali budur. Misal bak 12 üssü
3 dersem aslında 12 kaçta kaçın çarpımı?
Misal 3 de 4'ün çarpımı. E bunun üstünde
de kaç var? 3 var. Bu 3 hem buna ait hem
buna ait. Şimdi artık ne oldu? 3 üssü 3
x 4 üsü 3 şeklinde ifade edilebildi. Ki
sorularda gelen duruma göre böyle ne
yapacaksın? Tabanları
değiştirebileceksin. Peki hocam 2 üssü 6
2 üssü 4 çarpım durumunda tabanlar aynı
üstler ne yapıldı? Toplandı 2 üssü 10 4
üssü 3 5 üsü 3. Hocam bu sefer üstler
aynı tabanlar farklı. O zaman tabanlar
tek çatı altında toplanıyor. 4 x 5
tamamının üstünde 3 var. E 4 kere 5 20.
E o zaman cevap 20 üssü 3'tür. Şimdi gel
öğrendiğimizi hemen pratiğe dökelim.
Tabii ki bunlar kolay sorular. Çeğeri
temelli sorular geldiğinde gerçekten
orada zorlayacağım seni ama daha erken
daha öğreniyoruz konuyu. 4ün karesi x
4'ün 3. kuvveti. Hocam tabanlar
birbirine eşit olduğu için üstleri ne
yapıyoruz? Topluyoruz. 4 üzeri 5 gelir
mi? Bitti. Hocam tabanlar eşit olduğu
için üstleri ne yapıyoruz? Topluyoruz. 7
2 daha 9 1 daha ne yaptı? 10 12 üssü
10'dur cevabı. 7 7 var tabanlarda
üstleri topladın ama biri 5 diğeri -1.
Cevap ne kaldı? 7 üssü 4 kaldı hocam.
Tabanlar birbirine eşit. Üstler ne
yapılacak? Toplanacak -5 + 4'ten. Cevap
ne geldi? 6 üssü -1. E bunu da yazayım
ben bir zahmet. Rasyonel ifade. Takla
attırıyorduk. Üstünde negatif kuvvet var
hocam. Tabanlar hepsinde aynı. Üstleri
topluyorum. 4 3 daha 7'den 2 çıktı 5
zaten 0ının etkisi yok üssü 5 geldik
kritik yerlerden birine yine negatif
olunca bir şey olacak mı hocam hayır
neyse onu yapıyorsun taban aynı kalıyor
tabanlar aynıysa tabii topladım ne yaptı
8 2 daha ne yaptı 10 - 4 üzeri 10 bu
sayı aslında şuna eşit midir 4 üzeri
10'a niye üstü çift sayı olduğu için
içerideki eksiyi götürebilirsin peki 4
üzeri 10 da aslında 4 2 üssü 2'dir ya
onun da üstünde 10 var e üstlü bir ifade
var. Onun kuvvetini almışım yine. 2 üssü
ne geldi oradan? 20 geldi. En güzel
yazılmış hali bu. Şimdi tabanlar farklı
hocam. Üsler birbirinin aynısı olduğu
için 3 x 4'ün karesi buradan ne geldi?
12in karesi geldi. Yine üsler birbirinin
aynısı hocam. Tabanlar ne yapılıyor? Tek
çatı altında çarpılıyor. Tabii şöyle
yazmak daha şık gösterecektir. Üstte de
4 var. Eksiler birbirini götürdü. + 3
oldu içerisi. Üstünde 4'ümü yazdım.
Geldim yine bu tarafa. Uyuma bendesin
yalnız. Biliyor musun böyle çok şey
gitti. Hepsini çözüyoruz hocam. Daha
dur. Üstünde kuvvetin ne var? 3 var. O
zaman ne diyorum? -5 x 2. Onun da en
tepesinde 3 var. Hatta şunu bir daha
paranteze alırlar çıksun diye. İçeriyi
çarptım. Ne yaptı? -10 üssü 3 var. Peki
üssü tek kuvvet olduğu için ne
yapacağım? Eksiye bir şey olmaz hocam.
Hatta şöyle ayıracağım. Eksiye 10 üssü
3. Yine geldim hocam. Üstler birbirine
eşit. Ne yaptık? -2'mi yazdım? Çarp
-1'imi yazdım. En dışa ne yazdım? 5'i
yazdım. -2 ile -1'i çarptık. Ne yaptı? +
2 yaptı. Üstünde kaç var? 5 var. Buradan
da gelen cevap 2 üssü 5'tir dedik.
Geldik aşağıdakilere. Aşağıda verilen
üslü ifadelerin çarpımlarının
değerlerini bulunuz diyor. Bakalım
hemen. Hocam 9 diğeri 3. Ne taban aynı
ne üst aynı. Ne yapacağız? Olmuyor bu.
Çarpılmıyor. Dip geçecek miyiz? Hayır. 9
dediğin sayı aslında 3'ün karesi değil
mi? Onun da üstünde kaç var? 2. Yanda ne
var? 3 üssü 3 var. Devam ettim. Şimdi
sayı ne oldu? Bak üslü bir ifade
kuvvetini almışım. 2 kere 2'den 4 geldi.
Burada da 3 üssü 3 geldi. E tabanlar
aynı artık üstler toplanır. 3 üssü 7
benim cevabım olur. Geldim. Yine 2
tabanında yazılabilecek. Hepsi
birbirinden normalde farklı ama hepsi 2
tabanında yazılıyor. Hocam 2 üssü 1
aynen kalsın. 4 üssü 4. 4 dediğim sayı
2in karesidir. Üstünde 4 var. İki kuralı
birden kullanıyorum artık. 16. 16
dediğim sayı 2 üssü 4'tür. Üstün de
karesi var. Düzenle bakalım. 2 x 2 üzeri
2 kere 4'ten 8 x 2 x 4'ten 8. E hocam
burada üstte 1 var. Tabanlar aynı
üstleri topla. 8 8 16 1 daha 17 2 üssü
17. Bu soruda cevap. Anlaşılmayan nokta
yok değil mi? Bak 100 üzeri -2 10 üzeri
4 var. 100 üzeri -2 dediğinde aslında
10un karesi değil midir o ifade? Üstünde
kaç var hocam? -2. 10 üzeri üssü 4'e
dokunmuyorum. Peki buradan ne geldi? 10
üzeri 2 ile -2'yi çarptım -4 x 10 üsü 4.
Tabanlar eşit üstleri topladım 10 üssü
0. Onun da cevabı 1. 27 dediğim sayı
3'ün 3. kuvvetidir. Üstünde kaç var? 2
var. Çarpı 3'ün 2. kuvvetidir. 9 çarpı
yanında 3 var. Devam ettim. Şunu bir
sileyim karışmasın. Üslü bir ifadenin
kuvvetini almışım. 3 üssü 2 kere 3'ten
6. Üslü ifadenin kuvvetini almışım. 3
üssü 6. Tabanlar aynı. Üstleri topladın
3 üssü 12 aradığımız cevaptı. Geldim şu
arkadaşa şuradan devam edeyim. Aşağıda
boşluğum var hocam. Üstün üsü yani üslü
ifadenin üssü alınmış. O zaman direkt
çarpılır. O da nedir? 2 kere 5'ten 10
çarpa. 27 dediğim ifade nedir? 3 üssü
eksi pardon eksi yok 3 üssü 3 demektir
27 10un üstünde -2 var devam ettim 3
üssü 10 x 3 üssü burada üstlü ifadenin
üstü alınmış -6 işlemi yaptığımda
buradan geriye sadece kaç kalacaktır 3
üssü 4 kalacaktır yola devam 8 dediğim
sayı 2nin 3 kuvveti üstünde ne var -2 x
4 dediğim sayı 2in kares üstünde ne var
x 2 dediğim sayı zaten 4 kuvvet kuviyle
duruyor. Orada geldim bunları çarptım. 2
üzeri -6 x 2 üzeri + 6 x 2 üsü 4. Bak bu
üstleri topladığımda 2 üzeri 0 yaptı mı
diğeriyle toplamıyorum bile. Zaten
burası 1 yaptı. Cevap ne? 2 üzeri 4. 2
üzeri 4 de kolay sayı olduğu için direkt
yazayım istedim. Cevap 16'dır. Şimdi
eline kalemi alıyorsun. Kitabı
açıyorsun. Sayfa 10'a tike atıyorsun.
Arkadaş bir sayfa daha bitti. Adım adım
bütün kitabı beraber bitireceğiz
arkadaş. Şimdi burada bir rehberin notu
var. Önemli anlarda bazı özel soru
tarzları gelmeden önce bazen bu rehberin
notları gelecek. Ya da özel notlar
tutmamız gerektiğinde tabanları ve
üsleri farklı olan ifadelerin
çarpımından önce ortak üs
oluşturabilecek şekilde o çarpanları
ayırman gerekir. Üssü büyük olan ifade
parçalanır. Aynı [homurdanır] üslar tek
parantezle birleştirilir. Ne demek
istiyorsun hocam? Bak dikkatli. 2 üzeri
9 7 üzeri 6. Normalde çarpabilir miyim?
Ne taban aynı ne üst aynı. Hiçbir şey
aynı değil. Peki ne yapacağım hocam?
Şimdi
üssü büyük olan kim? 2 değil mi? Üstünde
9 var. Küçük olan kim? 6. Bunu 6'ya
kadar küçültmem lazım. Normal şartlarda
burada 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 tane yok mu? 2
üssü 9. E ben bu ifadeyi dilersem şöyle
yazamaz mıyım? 2 üssü 6 bu tarafta
dursun. 2 üssü 3 bu tarafta dursun.
Zaten çarpım durumunda tabanlar aynıysa
üstler toplanır. 2 üzeri 9. Demek ki bu
şekilde yazabilirim. Parçalıyorum. Tamam
mı? Parçaladım. 2 üssü 6 burada artık 7
üssü 6 bu tarafta ne var? Ortak üst var
hocam. Tabanlar aynı değil ama ortak üst
var. Bunlar tek çatı altında birleşecek.
2 üssü 3 yani şuradaki dışarıda kaldı. 6
var pardon 2 var buradan. Buradan 7 var.
Ortak üste geçtiler. 6. 2 kere 7 ne
yaptı? 14. Üstü duruyor. 14 üssü 6 2
üzeri kaçtı? 8. Bitirdim işi. Şimdi
benzer işlemleri burada yapalım. Hocam 3
üzeri 6, 5 üzeri 8 birleşemezler. Ne
tabanlar aynı ne üstler aynı. 5 üzeri 6
gerekli bana. E tamam da toplam 8 tane
vardı orada. İki tane elimde kaldı
hocam. Bak onu buraya yazdım. 5in karesi
nedir? Onu hesaplayalım mesela. 25.
Artık bu arkadaşlar ne olacak? Tek böyle
çatı altında birleşecekler. Yani 3 x 5
üssü 6 e 25 x bu da beni nereye
götürecek? 3 x 5 15 üssü 6'ya götürecek.
Geldim buraya. 2 üssü 9, 7 üssü 4. Kim
daha büyük? 2 üssü 9 daha büyük. O zaman
ben bunu 2 üssü 5, 2 üssü 4 diye ayırsam
dikkat et üstleri topla 2 üssü 9'u
veriyor zaten. 7 üssü 4'üm aynen
duruyor. Hocam bu arkadaşların tabanlar
farklı ama üstler aynı. Tek çatı altında
birleşecek. 2 üssü 5 x 2 x 7 üssü 4. 2
üssü 5 kaçtır? 32. 2 kere 7 kaçtır? 14.
Üstünde kaç var? 4. Hadi bitti. Bunu da
tokatladık. 4 üssü 7 3 üssü 5 hocam 4
üssü 7 dediğim ifade 3 üssü 5'e
yaklaşması lazım değil mi? 4ün karesi x
4 üssü 5 yazsam üstleri topla 7 yapıyor.
Tam istediğimiz değer. 3 üssü 5 de
burada mı? Mükemmel. Peki 4 üstünde biri
2 diğeri 5 var. Hocam ne yapalım burada?
Üstler artık şurada aynı olduğu için
işlemi alalım. 4'ün karesi burada
beklesin. 4 x 3 üssü 5'imi de yazdım mı?
E 4ün karesi 16. Bir zahmet çarpı ver. 3
kere 4 12. 12'nin üstüne kaçı yazdım?
5'i yazdım. Soruyu bitirdim. Geldim. 8
üssü 6 9 üssü 4. Hocam 8 üssü 6'yı 8
üssü 2 diye 8 üssü 4 çarpımı diye
ayırsak geldim buradan 9 üssü 4'ümü
yazdım. 8in karesi 64. Tabanları çarp
artık ne de olsa tek çatı altında
birleşeceğini biliyorum. 9 x 8 72 üssü
4. Hadi. Aha. Bir şey dikkatimi çekti.
E yok yok çekmedi. Bir şey oluyor mu
dedim de yok gelmiyormuş burada. Bu
kadar burada noktayı koydum. Şimdi
geldik şu ifadenin değerini bulmaya.
Hocam üslü bir ifade var üstünde çarpım
var. Çarptım geldim 3 üssü -6. Üstlü bir
ifade var üstünde çarpım var. Çarptım
geldim. 3 üssü 8. Buradan da 3 üssü 5
var. Hiçbir sıkıntı yok buraya kadar.
Üstler toplandı. -8 + 5'imi yazdım.
Şuradan 3 üssü kaç kaldı? 9 kaldı. 6 8
daha -14 + 5 daha ne yaptı? -9 yaptı. 3
üzeri -9 bu sorumuzun cevabı oldu.
Geldim 25. soruya. Bir geri dönüşüm
kampanyasında 64 mahallenin her birine 8
pil kutusu yerleştirilmiş. Şimdi önce ne
var? Mahalle var. Kaç tane? 64 tane
mahalle var. Her bir mahallede kaç tane
pil kutusu olacak? 8 tane 8 tane 8 tane
kaç tane mahalle var hocam? Nokta nokta
nokta buraya da 8 tane yazdım. 64 tane
mahalle var. 64 tane 8 var yan yana
senin elinde. Sonra yerleştirilmiş. Bu
kampanya sonunda her kutuda 125 atık pil
birikmiştir. Burada 125 tane var. Burada
125 tane var. Her kutuda diyor aman
Allah'ım 125 tane var. Burada 125 tane
var. Peki bu işlemi nasıl yapacağım
hocam ben? Normal şartlarda aslında
elinde kaç tane 8 var? Bak 8
+ nokta nokta + 8 dedim ya. Burada kaç
tane var aslında? 64 tane var değil mi?
Bunun anlamı nedir hocam? 64 x 8 tane ne
var? Pil kutusu var. Bak önce kaç tane
pil kutusu olduğunu buldum. 64 x 8.
Hatta bu da düzenlenebiliyor dedim. 64
dediğim sayı zaten 8in karesi. Onu da
8ile çarpıyorsun. Ne yaptı? 8'in 3.
kuvveti yaptı. Burada cepte. Devam
ettim. Her bir pil kutusunda da 125 tane
pil var. Bak pil kutusu her birinde a
tane var desem toplam pil sayısını
bulurum. Değil mi? Bunları çarparsam
eğer. Hocam pil kutusu kaç tane? 8 üssü
3 tane. A tane demiştim. E kaç tane pil
birikmiş her birinde? 125 tane. Bunları
çarpacağız. 8 üssü 3'ü aynen yazdım. 125
5'in 3. kuvvetidir. Düzeltip yazdım.
Hocam tabanlar değil ama üstler aynı.
Tek çatıda birleştirdim. 5 kere 8 40
üstüne 3'ü yazdım. Hatta hatta dedim ki
ben bunu hesaplarım hocam. Gel
hesaplayalım. Bak 4 yani 40 x 40 x 40 k
4 16 x 4 64. Sonuna da kaç tane 0
koydum? 3 tane 0 koydum. Demek ki bu
kadar adet ne varmış elimizde? Pil
varmış dedik. 20 dakikamızı doldurduk.
Seri halde videolar gelmeye devam
edecek. Üslü ifadelerde bölünebilme,
bölme işlemlerine geçeceğiz. Bol bol
soru çözeceğiz. Pratik yapacağız. Daha
sert sorular da sonraki derslerde
gelecek. Bir daha söylüyorum.
İzlemediysen o beceri temelli soruları
bir izle. Ondan sonra zaten görüşeceğiz.
Hadi bakalım RB tayfam 9. sınıf tayfam.
Rehbermatematik.com'da PDF'leri ücretsiz
indiriyoruz. Derslere eksiksiz
katılıyoruz. Sonraki dersten itibaren
videoda böyle yoklama alacağım. Tamam
mı? Yorumlarınızı okuyacağım. Yoklama
alacağım. Kendinize iyi bakın. Hoşça
kalın. Hoşça kalın.